I decide I want to leave and I told my
boss I want to leave and my boss takes
me out for this dinner and he told me a
story about a a Trader a young Trader at
deuts bank who you know nice guy good
Trader wanted to
leave the only problem is Deutsch didn't
really want him to leave you know so
they went through all of his looked
through some of his past trades and his
emails you know there wasn't really
anything in there but there was enough
you know there was a you know what I
mean enough to take him to court and he
rolled through court for years and years
and eventually the guy is
bankrupted then then he literally said
to me you know I like you I think you're
a good
person but sometimes bad things happen
to good people we can make life very
difficult for you you're going to find
out about that it's so obviously similar
to the way that like gangsters speak
that's exactly the same kind of person
that goes into drug dealer exactly the
same kind of person